man is facing murder charges after
fatally shooting a home Intruder in
Milton lawyer says 22 year old man is
facing a murder charge after allegedly
shooting a group of people who broke
into his Milton home over the weekend
police say a group of suspects entered
the home with an intent to commit her
arm robbery when they were confronted by
a man before a number of shots were
fired the criminal lawyer jagburg argues
his client should not be charged with
murder for shooting at an intruder that
broke into his home and attacked his
mother he is a registered firearm owner
so it is legal and used his gun legally
against the armed Intruder his intention
was not to kill and shoot only to shoot
at him once now it's not it's not legal
you can't do that harm owners are not
you can have the gun the gun's intent is
not to protect yourself here
if you have a gun let's say you have a
handheld like a a rifle not a rifle I'm
sorry if you have a handgun okay uh in
your house it is not made to protect
yourself only to go to the gun range
only to go to their gun range okay the
law tells you that you have to store
your gun
in one safe the bullets in the charge
the bullets has to be in a separate
locked compartment
and not in its charger okay so for you
let's say you have an intruder you have
to open one safe you have to open the
other safe put the bullets in the
charger then proceed to whatever you got
to do but it's not you cannot do that
you can't it's not meant to defend
yourself absolutely not
so yeah even though he is a gun owner
it's a self-defense with a firearm is
legal as long as you can prove that your
life was in danger through case law
shows that can be difficult to prove but
if if
the way they write it and they do it
it's likely that you're still going to
be charged for murder
it's written that no no if you but the
the the the the things that you have
the boxes that you have to check
for that to apply to you and ghost class
free
that you're gonna get you're gonna get
some time
you're gonna get some time so here are
the criteria
the criterias are the probabilities that
you believed on reasonable grounds that
a force or threat of force was being
used against them or another person
aka's mom you acted for the purpose of
Defending yourself or others from that
use of Forbes or a threat of force your
act perpetually committed in
self-defense was reasonable in the
circumstance which basically means you
didn't just run after them as they left
the house and kept shooting them in the
back or whatever it might be no but even
if they are still in the house or if
they surrender if they're in the house
and they go for your mom and you come
with your gun and they turn back and you
shoot him in the back you're done yeah
agree okay agree you're done you're done
so you it's so and all these things
happen in a split second right so just
the fact that he's like oh [__] no and
he turns yeah back because you betrayed
you saw someone exactly
exactly exactly so yeah even or or you
was he was doing like he was on the
perpetrator was on the mom and there's
another one you try to shoot and another
perpetrate comes between them you're
done so it's so messed up
I agree that it's like you have it's
like big game as a civilian
you have to exactly know how to act
under pressure which the police though
do not have
they don't they're not healthy that
standard okay I'll say this and I'll
make it super easy for everyone watching
just from my perspective I think this if
you break into someone's house your life
is forfeit I don't care if they shoot
you in the back I don't care if they
shoot you in their head I don't give a
[__] straight up if you break into their
home and you start attacking they should
kill you and kill everybody else
involves training why but what if they
surrender they better surrender and get
on their knees and floor and put their
hands out that not made me but if you
run it I don't know if you grab another
weapon I don't know what the [__] you
gonna do I'm not saying I'm blasted
that's what I would like to be able to
say not kidding apparently so you know
no not here but not here I feel like
that's how it should be I feel like
that's how if you are such a [__]
garbage piece of [__] that you do armed
home invasions and you attack people
they should kill you you are a [__]
scum ass person who not only attacks
people in their own homes makes that
place forever unsafe to them because who
wants to go back to a place where they
were [__] attacked okay that's one of
the most incredibly scary things that
you can go through when someone attacks
your mom like how paranoid you become
after that in your house in your house
like you destroy so much more I don't
give a [__] what happened to that person
throwing The Gallows lifes I don't care
oh how about your Beach I don't give a
[__] if you can't do stay away from
armbra I don't care what happens that's
really what you said if you
go inside someone's house yeah to Rob
them yay your life is forfeit I think
what if they got kids there you think
I'm gonna wait you think I'm gonna be
patient kill them
your life is forfeit I don't give a [__]
it's a whole ass rap you know you got no
siblings it's a wrap no no the legal
situation I think brings up a great
point and that's what the law says or at
least like case studies say he's like
it's very difficult to approve so you're
playing on dicey ground which is
unfortunate because in a place where
crime is starting to rise not to the
degree where it's like
the apocalypse we're still going up
fairly often it just it sucks that it
feels like the only people who have any
tools to defend themselves are the
people who shouldn't have the tools
meaning uh the criminals
so you asked me what I think listen
please response out here is slow by the
time they get there everything already
[__] up and you might be there so me I
would prefer to be able to do that and
defend myself but unfortunately that's
just not possible in this way so my
thoughts on all this I think this is
unfortunate I don't think the man should
be charged with anything man was
defending his mom for four people who
attacked him and while in what dude four
[__] bruh I got no sympathy for
them whoever's dead good okay and the
other ones go as well I'm fine with it
too because if you would attack my
mother I would have wished way more on
you way more if I don't found out four
[__] did that tomorrow I would
have wished way more and you best
believe I would have unloaded that whole
clip on them if they were doing that in
front of me no there's no way did she
get an attacked by fourth grown ass man
and I tell you this is one this is one
of the few things that pees me the most
about being in this country is these
kind of stupid laws I get we don't want
to be America that's fine and that's
great by the idea we share a border with
them and criminals out here they just
they just drive stuff they get their gun
they come back up it's that easy
it's not hard to smuggle that [__]
because guess what the Canadian and
American Border is large as
so if you want to bring stuff across the
border it's not the most difficult thing
in the world have you guys ever done
those border crossings I have they don't
check your car vigorously have you done
it yeah what was your experience
depends but I go there many times so
there's gonna be sometimes that I'm
gonna be checked of course but sometimes
you don't know sometimes you literally
just drive right through [__] sometimes
there's nobody at the game
that's my point and that you're going
through the popular ones or the more
popular ones sometimes you don't have
when you know the ones there's some that
are not popular at all and there's
nobody Manning you go through New
Brunswick New fine that's what I'm
saying you're fine you're going to be
going you're going through New Brunswick
it's going to be nice it's gonna be one
lady there and if you don't look too
suspicious or she knows you it is what
it is in the bag of chips and even if
they okay is that they don't they
generally don't check thoroughly if the
person is alone the person's not
checking okay if it's if it's 12 at
night that person is alone
on the middle of the middle of the week
they are not checking so so all I'm
trying to say is this things are getting
more dangerous we've seen a huge spike
in gun crime in the areas that we live
at and whether we like it or not there's
a serious conversation to be had about
whether or not you should be able to
defend yourself if you're a responsible
gun owner who takes care of their weapon
and trains with it I'm all for you being
able to use that in those kinds of
situations because guess what if he
didn't have that weapon on him who's to
say that he wouldn't be the one that's
buried in the undead and his mom and
this would have been a tragedy in Milton
instead the man [__] saved his loved
one they get to Live Another Day do you
know how the cops don't have to don't
don't have to train every month or every
week they don't have to
they don't have to shoot their guns
every [__] they have to shoot once a
year meaning I have more training than a
cop
okay so
I have to go through all this [__] and I
still cannot defend myself yeah and I
have to know exactly how to act under
pressure but they don't they're not up
to that standard right right and they're
cops cops so not only can they just go
about God have anything in this Chiefs
do their thing right without the proper
training I can't do that [__] I can't
protect myself in my house I gotta call
them and they don't have the property
and I have more training that's what
this is not even a story about cops and
priest hates cops that much dude man
that's one thing that triggers them
right